はぁ
ああああああ
wh
あーこ後メジャー所社長です上で私は今ちょっと畑を借りで畑にいるんですけどもね
同じことを2回って気がする丁寧な反対へといえば農作業持つ皆さん
サツマイモご存知でしょうかはいこちらですね薩摩よってとがあるんですけども
サツマイモてどう捉えるかと言いますとねが後薩摩ようにつれ額を23個つながってて
こうなってるイメージ群馬ゆけ
のサツマイモが5個6個ツールにするネック繋がってるイメージあるんですけども
そんなんじゃ足りねえだというわけで今日の動画ですね今からターゲットを読んでなぜ
かさつま芋を掘るという意味不明動画とると思うんですけどもその
ホッターサツマイモの100連結ドッキリやっていきたいとおもいます
続いてこちらのサツマイモ100個準備しました樋本方が色々買ったんでいいでしょ
まあいいでしょ
って引っ張ったらキャートッパーっとやっていきたいとおもいます水で早速サツマイモ
100個つながっているツールの詰めしていこうと思います fear グッパイ
ファーマーズウェイ早速100円月のサツマイモのをする作っていこうと思います
100個の妹に穴を開けましたこの穴にとりあえず見えるひもを通していけば何か釣れ
っぽくなると思って気はしますなかなかで撮っツールを表現する
っていうのは難しかったんだけど女形の土で汚れでビニール紐と貨物に一瞬年は見える
と思うんですよねその一瞬ねっとりあえず100円ケツしてるさつま芋って思わせれば
もうこちらの持ってるんでまずは100円月している状態を作っていきますはいいき
ますできますちゃいました
大いう間ですねいいんじゃないでしょうかこんな感じですねそれでこういうことは作り
まくってきます
[音楽]
goo
バッハは
バッハ
[音楽]
[拍手]
あっはぁん
tai
さあワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
と言え分 g 8寂光眼睛
いやー我ながらに結構ちゃんと出来てると思いますねまだちょっとベリールが白いんで
ちゃった目立つんですけどこれは何だか土にいればいい感じに色が変わるのかなと思っ
ておりますエコカーなんですけど引っ張んた時にピンってなるよいいものぬの端っこ壁
に縛りますので一回色々
deji
方無理かぁってあって僕でもチラガー
二たったったっん
これいいやという場で重くて無理だったんでこのまま持ち上げても問題ないかなと思い
ますねここから割も前に売れなきゃ入っていいかと思いますがそれっぽい機械化して
いただいたのでこれなんか適当にやってあなぁけどそこにポイします今井
[音楽]
おきゃー一応もうちょっと深いと思っております
強い日もここに移します
[音楽]
知っも見えましたーーー
どんな本材
[音楽]
はい峠でどうでしょうかちょっと雑感茶色くて分かりやすいと思うんですけどもこの9
に用がありますと
に隠れてここだけちょっとだけに方が出てるんでここを放っぽぬけばダーって100個
出るっていう感じでございますではターゲットのトサカを待ちましょう
[音楽]
ちょっと到着しました嫌がっちゃけ
何しにここに来た仮想農業宜しくお願いします
ただのオタクじゃねーっ本当に内定で圭介さんはい
時代は何かわかりますか時代はご覧の通り
田んぼデー自足なんですよ端までをないでさしこでもないですけどなんかここにいいー
alsa 構図がもう増えてやるとどっちですか
その辺が止まってるらしいんですロッキーんだそれを持って帰っていたしてって言っ
てるものを抜く酒居たませんじゃ
ed avg というわけで今日ここにあるの
そり放題で字なつないだよ
うまく言えませんで早速さんが専用陶器受皿みましょう
ねっ
すごいどっか休んでしっかり食べちゃうぞ
強くををっ
応答はずですね
[音楽]
んで5
ですまだでどんなはっはがある
えっ
[音楽]
でっ頂けグッズパンッと言ああ
ああああああああ
[拍手]
goo
[音楽]
[拍手]
ran 言われてるよ
ん
えっえっえっ
ああああああああああああ
フロリダ分わざわざ le tan
ああああああ
んだよねなんだなぁあ
[音楽]
はいというわけで音像校向かって抜いたら
サツマイモ100個術グッズドッキリでした
山は
被毛というわけで俺したらめちゃスケドッキー
失敗